So, Michael, I want to try to convince
you other than the fact that it's an algorithm
with symbols that, it sort of works, at, at
least informally. And then, I'm going to do what I
always do and refer you to actually read
the, the, the text to get the, the details.
But before I do that, I wanted to go
through an example if you think that would help.
>> I would like an example.
>> Okay. So, let's go through an example. So, here's a very simple
example. So, I got three little boxes on the screen. Can you see them?
>> Yeah.
>> Now,
they're the same boxes. I've drawn them up here beforehand
because I'm going to solve this problem in only three steps.
>> Hey those boxes are really nice, did
you get help from our trusty course developer?
>> I did in fact did get help from our trusty
course developer. And when I say help, I mean he did this.
>> Oh thanks Push Car.
>> Yes Push Car is wonderful. Now what's
really cool about this is that Push Car is
already let you know that we're going to be
able to do this in 3 simple steps. And
I'm going to be able to animate it. Or at least hopefully
it'll look animated by the time, [LAUGH] we're done with all
the editing. So just pay attention to the first box for
now, you have a bunch of data points; red pluses and
green minuses, which is the opposite of what we usually do
Push Car. But either way it's red pluses and green minuses.
[LAUGH] With the appropriate labels and they all live in this,
this part of the plane. By the way, what do you call
a part of the plane? I know you have
line segments, what's like, a sub part of a plane?
>> Looks like a square to me.
>> Yes it is, but I mean, what do you call them? You,
you don't call it a plane segment, do you? What do you call it?
>> A region.
>> A square region, fine. So it's a square region on a plane. And we
want to figure out how to be able to correctly classify these examples. Okay, so
that is nothing new there. We just want to be able to come up with
something. So now we have to do what we did like in the quiz is that
we have to specify what our hypothesis space is. So
here's our hypothesis space. So the hypothesis space is the set
Of axis aligned semi-planes. You know what that means?
>> Mm, no.
>> Well for the purpose of this example it means,
I'm going to draw a line, either horizontal or vertical and say
that everything on one side of that line is positive
and everything on the other side of that line is negative.
>> I see. Okay, good.
>> Right. And their axes align because it's only
horizontal and vertical, and they're semi-planes because the positive part
of it is only in part of the plane. Okay, so I'm
going to just walk through what boosting would end up doing with this particular
example or what a boosting might do with this particular example given that
you have a learner. That always chooses between axis aligned semi planes. Okay?
>> Yeah.
>> So let's imagine we ran our boosting algorithm
now in the beginning it's step 1 all of the
examples look the same because we have no particular reason
to say any are more important than the other, any
are easier or harder than the other. And that's just
the algorithm we had before We run through and we ask
our learner to return some hypotheses that does well in
classifying the examples. It turns out that though there are many,
and in fact there are an infinite number of possible
hypotheses you could return. One that works really well is one
that looks like a vertical line that separates
the first two data points from the rest.
>> That is what I was guessing.
>> Of course it was. And what I'm saying here is that everythign to
the left of this line is going to be positive and everything to the right
is going to be negative. So if you look at this what does this hypothesis do? So
it gets correct, correctly labeled positive. The two pluses to the left. Right?
>> Correct.
>> And it gets correct all of the minuses as well.
>> Right? But it gets wrong the three pluses on the
right side. So it gets, this wrong, this wrong, and this wrong.
>> Right, the Three Plusketeers.
>> Exactly. [LAUGH] The Three Plusketeers. That's
actually pretty good. So I'm just you know
I'm just going to ask you to trust me here but it turns out that the specific
error here is 0.3 and if you stick that into our little alpha you end up,
our little, our little formula for alpha, you end up with alpha equal to 4.2.
>> That's not obvious to me but.
>> Is is See, see, see it's not always obvious.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Okay. Good. So there you go and that's
just what happens when you stick this particular set in
there. So now we're going to construct the next distribution.
Right? And what's going to happen in the next distribution?
>> So the one's that it got right should get less weight and the one's that
it got wrong should get more weight so
those three plusketeers should become more prominent somehow.
>> That's exactly what happens. They become, I'm just going to draw them
as much thicker and bigger to kind of emphasise that they're getting
bigger, and it's going to turn out that everything else is going
to get smaller which is a lot harder to draw here. So i'm
just going to kind of leave them their
size, so they sort of get normalized away. Okay?
>> I would guess as to what the next plane should be. I think that we should
cut it. Underneath those pluses but above the green
minuses. And that should get us three errors. The
two pluses on the left and the minus on
the top will be wrong. But they have less
weight than the three pluses we got right, so
this going to be better than the previous one.
>> So,
that's possibly true. But it's not what the learner output.
>> Oh!
>> Let me tell you what the learner did output though. This learner
output by putting a line to the right of the three pluses, because
he's gotta get those right in saying that everything to the left is
in fact, positive. So, does that seem like a reasonable one to you?
>> Well, it does better than half. I guess that's really all what we're
trying to do, but it does seem to do worse than what I suggested.
>> Well, let's see, it gets the three
that mattered that you were really, really doing poorly
right but then so did yours. And it only,
and it picks up still the other two which
it was getting right. And it gets wrong these
three minus' which aren't worth so much. So is
that worse than what you suggested? No, it gets
wrong, oh, the three minuses. Oh, it gets correct
those two red pluses on the left. So it gets three things
wrong. So that's just as good as what I suggested. Okay, I agree.
>> Okay good. So the error of this step by the way, turns out
to be 0.21 and the alpha at this time step turns out to be 0.65.
So that's pretty interesting, so we got a bunch of these right and a bunch of
these wrong. So what's going to happen to the distribution over these examples.
>> Alright, the ones that it, again, the
ones that it got wrong should get pushed up
in weight and which ones are those, those are
the, the three green minuses in the middle patch
>> Right.
>> They should become more prominent. The pluses, the three, the three
plusketeers should become less prominent than they were but it still might be
more prominent than they were in the beginning. And maybe because in fact
the alpha, let's see the alpha is bigger so, it will have actually
a bigger effect on bringing it down.
>> Yeah I guess so, but it, there'll still be
more prominent than the other ones that haven't been bumped.
>> Yeah the ones that you, the, the two, the two
red pluses on the left have, you've never gotten them wrong.
>> Hm.
>> So they're really going to disappear. So, if we do, If I
do my best to, If I do my best to kind of draw
that you're still, you're going to have. These pluses are going to be a
little bit bigger than the other pluses, but they're going to be smaller than
they were before. The two, the three greens in the middle are
going to be bigger than they were before. But those two pluses
are going to be even smaller, and these two minuses are going to
be smaller. So, what do you think the third hypothesis should be.
>> Quiz.
>> Oh, I like that.